health questions dominated us defense
secretary Lloyd Austin's first press
conference of
2024 Austin said he has apologized to
President Joe Biden for not telling him
when he first was diagnosed with
prostate cancer but what Austin wanted
to focus on was the multiple conflicts
in the Middle East starting with the
Drone attack that killed three US
soldiers in northeastern Jordan Austin
said the Iranian backed proxy behind the
attack will be held responsible you know
I don't think the uh the adversaries are
of a oneandone
mindset uh and so uh they have a lot of
capability I have a lot more before his
surgery Austin had overseen the buildup
of US Navy vessels in the region in part
to protect cargo ships from houti
attacks in the Red Sea attacks Austin
called unacceptable the hooes continue
to do some things that are very uh
irresponsible and illegal and uh and so
our goal is to make sure that we take
away we continue to take away capability
from the hotis uh to do what they've
been doing and then there's the war in
Gaza where the death toll has surpassed
27,000 men women and children when asked
by Al jazer if he has done enough to
pressure Israel to avoid killing more
civilians Austin said we talked to him
about that uh weeks ago uh and uh they
said they were going to do that and they
are doing that but I will continue to
emphasize and I know secretary blinkin
and President Biden will continue to
emphasize the importance of addressing
the issue of the Palestinian people uh
it it's critical and uh you know we're
doing more uh but but we're not doing
enough Lloyd Austin wanted to show his
health isn't interfering with his job
and given that the President says he has
full confidence in Austin it's back to
work for the defense secretary
Rosalyn Jordan aljazera the
Pentagon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer